y hoy iremos directo a madrid porque el
gobierno español destituyó a la
directora del centro nacional de
inteligencia
hablamos de paz esteban esto luego de
que se conociera que invente
independentistas vascos y catalanes
fueron víctimas de espionaje incluso los
teléfonos del jefe del ejecutivo pedro
sánchez y de los ministros de defensa y
del interior fueron interceptados con el
programa israelí pegasus a la cabeza del
cn y quedó esperanza casteleiro genera
la secretaria de estado de defensa
conectamos entonces con nuestra
corresponsal marina colorado marina un
gusto saludarla y cuéntenos por qué fue
destituida paz y esteban
pues según el gobierno la hasta hoy
directora del centro nacional de
inteligencia paz esteban no fue
destituida sino sustituida argumentando
un cambio de dirección en el cine y al
final el resultado es el mismo esteban
deja su cargo tras semanas de escándalos
por el espionaje a varios líderes
catalanes y vascos la ministra de
defensa ha evitado dar las razones por
las que la han sustituido sin embargo la
semana pasada la ahora ex directora del
cine y habría confirmado en una reunión
a puerta cerrada con varios diputados
que efectivamente el servicio secreto de
españa' espió con autorización de la
justicia a 18 independentistas entre los
cuales está el actual presidente del
gobierno de cataluña pere aragonès
allegados del expresidente catalán
carles puigdemont y varios integrantes
del movimiento tsunami democrático que
en 2019 convocó a marchas en las calles
de barcelona tras la sentencia judicial
a líderes independentistas pero el
espionaje que más incomoda al ejecutivo
es el que sucedió hace más de un año sin
aparente conocimiento del cn a los
teléfonos del presidente del gobierno de
la ministra de defensa el del ministro
del interior y al de la ex ministra de
asuntos exteriores algo que refleja
graves brechas en la seguridad del
centro que lideraba paz esteban y
finalmente porque su destitución es un
paso más para calmar los ánimos de los
socios de investidura de pedro sánchez
que pedían transparencia y depurar
responsabilidades' marina y cuáles han
sido las reacciones a la destitución o
la sustitución de pas esteban
dependiendo de por donde se mire
precisamente desde los socios de
investidura y de coalición del gobierno
aceptan la destitución como lógica
aunque piden total transparencia para
que no se vuelva a repetir el espionaje
algo a lo que se ha mostrado dispuesto a
la ministra de defensa margarita robles
quien ha dicho que estaría a favor de
que se desclasifiquen las autorizaciones
judiciales que dieron lugar a este
espionaje por otro lado el partido
popular partido líder de la oposición y
el de ultraderecha vox lo ven como un
paso que debilita al estado y además
afirman que esto deja en muy mala
posición al centro nacional de
inteligencia a poco más de mes y medio
de la cumbre de la otan que se celebra
en madrid a finales de junio la
destitución de paz esteban no parece ser
suficiente para disipar la crisis del
espionaje en el gobierno español
mientras tanto el parlamento europeo
anunció que prevé incluir a españa y a
eeuu en la lista de países a los que
enviará una misión de investigación
sobre las escuchas lista en la que hasta
el momento sólo estaban incluidos israel
país de origen del programa pegasus
y polonia naciones cuyos gobiernos
habían admitido abiertamente haber
comprado y utilizado este software de
espionaje marina gracias por este
reporte desde madrid' nosotros
continuamos con más información aquí en
directo américa